ja ja muss loswurde heute hat sie kommen
zu anderen video kürze fallen in der
stelle
was denkt ihr braucht man um eine
glückliche beziehung zu führen eine
glückliche ehe zu führen und auch in
einer familie glücklich zusammenzuleben
ok ja liebe ja ok respektvolle man
stimmt auch das war's sollte das auch
meine leute muss ich euch leider darauf
hinweisen dass sie an der stelle falsch
liegt für ein glückliches familienleben
braucht man auch eine vierte zu tat und
die ist mobbing so zu sehen in dem hilfe
die video meinen man mobbt mich jetzt
reicht's was mir vor ein paar tagen
vorgeschlagen wurde
schon allein war auch das land das ich
habe die frau darauf die ewig gemobbt
wird und sie wird als salat
naja also leute stelle ich auf
tieffliegende salat gefallen denn wir
legen jetzt los und ganz wichtig wenn
ihr einen 50 euro gutschein gewinnen
wollt dann seid einfach immer unter den
ersten 20 mit video kommentieren die
ganze aktion läuft bis zum 20
helfen und wie es macht ganz einfach
glock aktivieren deaktivieren könnte den
ersten 20 seiten hat eine gute chance zu
gewinnen
okay wir sind wohl die letzte leg mich
am arsch hat hier vor mir angeschlagen
schaut aus wie auf einer müllhalde
wo ist mein frühstück die hat ihm gesagt
hab hier sehen wir zutat nummer vier für
eine glückliche beziehung in vollem
effekt der mann kommt natürlich morgens
in die küche sieht seine frau da wie sie
den abwasch macht und das erste was man
natürlich macht ist man klar ihr könnt
natürlich jetzt auch zunehmend zeigen
das ist auch zutat aber er geht direkt
zu platzieren und mob die alte erstmal
ordentlich
du weißt doch genau dass sich dieses
modell nicht marc roger okay sind alle
gerade erst aufgestanden ja entspannt
nicht es ist wahrscheinlich sieben uhr
morgens irgendwo in deutschland der
seine frau schon denke ich okay und dann
kommt die liebe rein mache ich weiß das
ist kein wort verdammt noch mal
ich will nur pferde sagen ich brauche
was ordentliches zubeißen gefreut mal
los mach mal was für die familie
dies sind aus stahl jetzt krieg ich die
grenze für sehr dafür dass buttermesser
schon der hand okay okay jetzt sie nora
nora und die man ruhig wird erstmal ein
salatkopf übrigens allgemein guter
ratschlag in einen möglichen stress
situationen im leben zum beispiel mal
sitzen der klausur und die ganzen zahlen
steigen einem über den kopf erstmal ein
salatkopf werfen wollte man ja mal ein
bisschen mit anpacken würde wird hier
auch nicht so krass aussieht wieso es
ist nicht mein job wird sie nicht mehr
brauchen hilfe folge vorbei warum habe
ich dich überhaupt geheiratet nichts
weitergegangen
ganz im ernst was passiert der käse denn
alter er heiratete sie gerade dann mit
er morgens kein mortadella euro
investieren dann wird er morgen seine
fans
wir bekommen und was passiert dann hatte
die alte am bein hat die hochzeit
bezahlt hat sonst was bezahlt ja dann
konnten wir uns nicht kaputt da kann man
noch mal seine ehefrau bomben greift
organisiert seine frau und demütigt sie
am laufenden band mit grund wohlgemerkt
sie wollte die moderatorin nora ist nur
noch eine befehls empfängerin und ralf
ist quasi der feldwebel zuhause ich an
ihrer stelle würde alles hinschmeißen
und sagen bis 4 und alter und nicht
weitermacht an dreck alleinig anderer
stelle würde mir einen salatkopf greifen
und ihn auf meinen ehemann werfen und
dann sagen alter bis hierhin und nicht
weiter ganz wichtig ist das alter was
die expertin ihrem vorhin hat ja also
ohne alltag wird der satz auch nicht
richtig macht dir deinen frühstücksbrot
doch allein sind nicht einmal zusammen
frühstücken wie ganz normale menschen
nein darauf zu nerven erst mal täler
broten den euro
wir wollen wie normale menschen
frühstücken können uns nicht normale ehe
paar falten nein nein es bleibt alles so
wie hier etwas sehen
hast du dich schon mal angesehen
schwierig wird's richtig gezogen
ich muss ganz ehrlich sagen mir fehlt du
bist dann so dass vergleich objekt um
diesen vergleich zu bewerten wie sieht
denn jemand aus der rückwärts durch
direkte gezogen wurde so ja so schon und
wie unterscheidet man so rein vom
aussehen her zwischen die man der
vorwärts durch die hecke gezogen wurde
und jemand der rückwärts richtig gezogen
wurde
kein wunder dass man sowas nicht am
tisch sitzen haben will
ich bin eine frau du bist nur hausfrau
also sie ist noch hausfrau hat er dann
mehrere frauen oder wie eine hausfrau
eine garten frau eine kino frau einem
brauch können siehst du dich wohl von
spiegel gegeben und ich etwas auf
restaurieren
also schon wieder krieg diesmal wieder
ein
die kinder damit ich war gerade schon
sagen sogar zur frage wo sie können das
sachen ebenso wieder ganzen war der
morgen papa und mama sie ist kurz
vermeulen steht da als würde sie
körperlich missbraucht ganz normaler tag
keinen grund darüber zu intervenieren
ihr kennt ja party machen abends aber
kennt ihr danach nicht mal ist zeigt lag
räumen
nein es hat ihre aufgabe als hausfrau na
also man hat es ja gerade schon mal in
seiner genetischen noch einmal
präzisiert das ist ihre aufgabe ist
hausfrau zu sein soll
nein natürlich können sich nicht
verwerfen die überreste der wilden party
von gestern für vier bierflaschen und so
drei pizzakartons ging richtig ab erst
jetzt so ab er ich will das gucken aber
nicht einmal in ruhe fernsehen ohne dass
irgendwer dazwischen redet hast du
vergessen nachzudenken
das ist eine gute frage sie hat doch
jetzt verlässt nachzudenken
hier haben alle nachgedacht also du als
als ehemann ralf eure kinder die haben
auch alle nachgedacht weil ich mein wenn
man sich überlegt wie gut unsere mutter
steht da ist am rande der tränen ist
kurz davor zu kollabieren natürlich hat
man weiter auf warum die am nachgedacht
aber die mutter mich mama kannst du kurz
mal auf hin zu arten und ich will
fernsehschauen noch unfassbar leid denn
ihr mann behandelt sie wie ein
putzlappen er redet schlecht mit ihr
ergeht respektlos mit ihr um jaja so
behandle ich auch noch meine putzlappen
[Musik]
herr sebastian können wir bitte etwas
mehr zeit miteinander verbringen
aber ich habe doch auch gefühle nicht zu
viel gefühl dass die melder und sagt
komm wir fahren da wir auch endlich mal
wieder nach hause wollen wir denn was
ist dir gut gehen lassen
hast du spaß gehabt in deinem leben
eigentlich sollten sich 1004 einkaufen
und dann ich habe keinen bock mehr haft
einige ausreden du warst doch bestimmt
wieder bei dieser beschissenen honig
macht mir mal wieder essen kochen wir
was das ist ein job ja jemanden hat es
direkt gewittert sie war bei ihrer
freundin war sie tatsächlich den part
habe ich noch ausgestellt weil ja nicht
sagt das war hier ein beweisbild leute
sie war tatsächlich nora war tatsächlich
bei ihrer freundin nora wir müssen uns
erklären diesen 10
da brauche ich mir nicht geben weißt du
was ich gegen die kneipe ich habe mich
ja schon daran gewöhnt dass du hässlich
geworden bist halt also 200 wir sind
natürlich auf einer wellenlänge
wir behandeln alle unsere mitmenschen
die putzlappen
vor allem mal ganz kurze frage
zwischendrin so ralf das ist ja
angeblich so der mann im haus nur das
geld verdient und der seine frau
herumkommandiert wie so ein idiot ne so
was was macht er
er ist zum mittagessen zu hause also um
zwölf oder 13 uhr und geht dann erst mal
die kneipe roboter kann sein dass du
auch nicht arbeitest du hast du willst
dich wie du willst ich koch weist ihr
schmeckt wie ist es dir gut genug was du
heute im einzige frühstückt oder was ja
ja ja ja nur ein einziges frühstückt er
ja dies sollte auch ganz kranken wählen
unterwegs also habe ich auch noch nie so
gesehen bei der will auf einmal nicht
mehr beleidigt werden kritisiert dass
sie extrem viel gibt in der beziehung
und der mann gar nichts geht
hast du etwa menschen mit gesundem
menschenverstand gefrühstückt was
vergessen wer die kohle nach hause
bringt ja du sicher nicht du bist zum
mittagessen zu hause und gestern nach
laufen also du bringst die kohle euch
nach hause macht schokolade mit kokos
gekauft das ist das falsche ist verklebt
total die haare ich habe schon tausend
mal gesagt welches zu kaufen seit mobit
kreis moment lässt kommt kinder war die
küche kochen macht okay also die preis
abständen jetzt okay ich fange jetzt
verlässlich geworden gibt es jetzt den
zu sein und mein gott hast du etwa die
schokolade mit kokos
auch jetzt doch trotz geballter macht es
spaß wenn ich habe es dir schon so oft
beleidigt muss zur schule der bus fährt
gleich zur schule
ich kann gerade nicht sie ist es nicht
hat das level gleich geschafft okay
leute da ist es dann wirklich auch
langsamer komplett verteidiger ok
morgens in deutschland die mutter sie
hat sich zumindest mal aufgestellt okay
sie arbeitet ein bisschen an sich will
versuchen ihr selbstbewusstsein zurück
zum kompost wohnzimmer sie die studie
[Musik]
sollte aufhören zu spielen und in die
schule zu gehen
das ist doch krank jetzt reicht's jetzt
geht's los heute jetzt alle einmal eine
kirche aufstellen dann gibt es beim gibt
es salat endlich die ganze folge
überfordert schon das ähnlich der salat
geworfen wird zu therapiezwecken jetzt
ist es soweit
38 baby da war nur davon zu schwimmen
ja ja ja so was kann man dazu sagen also
wenn ihr in der familie oder sonstwo mit
freunden immer so weiter probleme habt
dann fange einfach an dinge zu werfen so
artikuliert auf keinen fall eure
probleme oder sagt was euch stört wert
immer erst dinge am besten salatköpfe
alternativ kann man aber auch wir jetzt
hier zum beispiel sieht zeitschriften
werfen oder klamotten oder handtücher
bettdecke ist auch okay so hat für euch
wenn ihr die 50 euro amazon gutschein
gewinnen wollt bis zum 17 11
dann wie gesagt seid immer unter den
ersten 20 im video kommentieren am
besten indem er die glocke aktiviert
hier bekommt ihr einfach ich vorschlage
das video hier könnt ihr mal abonnieren
danke fürs schon heute sagen macht's gut